in a letter obtained by cbs news a
director of the cdc is calling on all
states
to have vaccine distribution sites quote
fully operational by november first
that of course is just two days before
the general election and months before
even the most optimistic timeline
mark straussman is outside the cdc in
atlanta for us mark good morning to you
what more do we know about this letter
well good morning tony for starters that
letter came out on august 27th that's
the same day that president trump gave
his acceptance speech
at the republican national convention a
speech in which he teased that a vaccine
could come out by the end of the year
the worry here is that this plan may
have more to do with politics
than with science now that said many
health experts
agree that having a distribution plan in
place is essential
even if the vaccine needs more work
whether we end up with a vaccine sooner
or later we need those plans we need
those logistics in place
dr jesse goodman is the former chief
scientist at the fda
he oversaw several vaccine approval and
distribution efforts
goodman is concerned that the new letter
from the cdc
did not come sooner we have safety
effectiveness quality good logistics and
distribution system
a safety monitoring system and we don't
screw up the trust
safe and effective vaccine can save
lives
but that's a tall order to come up with
in the remaining time before then
dr goodman worries that political
pressure on the fda
could lead the public to doubted safety
and effectiveness
but both fda commissioner dr stephen
hahn and
dr anthony fauci said no vaccine would
be approved or granted emergency
authorization
without sound data and science behind it
i would not be comfortable
with a vaccine unless it was shown in a
clinical trial
clearly to be safe and effective now
with
labor day weekend approaching the
nation's top health officials are urging
americans to remain
disciplined to avoid behaviors that led
cases to spike following memorial day
and the 4th of july on a trip across the
midwest
dr debra burks of the white house
coronavirus task force
gave this stern warning when i say
socially distanced it means at all times
including with family members
we are seeing that crowded neighborhood
events
including backyard barbecues are
currently one of the primary spreaders
of virus
burks's tour comes as several states
report spikes in new covenant cases
including iowa
the white house recently flagged iowa as
having the highest rate per capita of
new covid cases
and there is also a spike in south
dakota which recently hosted the sturgis
motorcycle rally
and that event has been linked to almost
300 new cases
in a dozen states anthony mark strassman
thank you mark